All right, everyone.
Today.
I have a very great news.
We are about to speak with our first coordinator on mainnet.
So if you guys were following Crunch a couple of weeks back.
We introduced this new role on testnet called the coordinators. And coordinators are other entities in the world of decentralized AI that would like to tap into the power of Crunch.
And the first coordinator that reached mainnet, meaning that managed.
Managed to develop the smart contract necessary to interact with Crunch is called Synth and I am here in New York with his founder.
James.
How are you, James?
It's great to have you here.
Today.
The main subject is the Synth coordinator.
So first and foremost.
What are you guys building.
Gents.
On this subnet and what kind of product are you actually putting out out of it?
It's super exciting because we are particularly fan of these approaches that are more probabilistic instead of, you know, predicting price.
And actually.
I don't agree.
A lot of people make that mistake and try to predict price and end up in this very.
Very noisy environment that is extremely hard to model.
Whereas here you had two layers.
Not only you try to predict a distribution of price.
But you also had many vectors with many.
Researcher and so my next question would be how did you end up in this setup why did you choose to go for decentralized AI setup and why is it making so much sense for a product like that.
It's a very complex problem to solve.
I think people don't realize that when you come in the market and you try to build a quant algorithm or you try to predict market.
You actually compete with a huge team of quant and researchers with other company that are injecting millions, if not hundreds of millions every year in mine every little bit of information that can help them.
Them trying to understand you know what will be this distribution of returns and etc and so i think in your setup there is not only the stability but also the predictive power and alpha that you can get from there because you can attract people from you know.
Vast different background and by the way guys you don't need to understand finance to do and to compete at Crunch at Crunch and at Synth on the coordinator of Synth on Crunch it's just pure price distribution like you look at time series kind of and and of course you can inject a lot of other kind of feature and maybe that's something you want to touch base.
We didn't talk about the scoring.
You mentioned the reward.
Maybe quick word on the scoring. How do you assess the best submission?
What is the scoring metrics and how do you really?
Prevail on top of people that try to actually cheat the subnet or cheat the coordinator.
It's live scoring. So there is there is it's the best protection against any kind of of cheating.
Right? And.
You know, we were having this discussion before where we said.
Okay, you can have a very hard training and you're going to be scored on live data on a live ring with everyone else looking at you.
And so if you fake the training or you overfit, you know, the data set.
Said you're going to get destroyed on the ring there is no there is no shortcut like live market was to call your algorithm the way you would have been scored on a proper trading strategy and on top of that you have yeah I guess people can choose their strategy but you have these negative incentives in the mining slot and so guys don't worry because I know you're not used to that crunch is working a lot on reputation for a long time and we're a bit more paternalist let's say so we will kind of help.
Help people in building meta model out of all the submission on crunch and then submit this meta models into mining slots except of course if someone is like really performing alone on crunch then we'll probably plug him directly into things because in the end crunch try to solve that right the complexity of opening a mining slot of paying for the mining slots maybe you can try more things on crunch because you won't have you know the time to test and the money.
That you're gonna do so you can be a bit more creative maybe and end up participating in mining without the negative incentive you still have to build your reputation on crunch and for that reason we have this one month warm-up during which we will just look at the submission and the model before actually starting registering mining slots into synth.
Well, believe me, it's not easy. It's exciting but.
Not easy. So we started to look a bit at the, you know, what were the performance of the different miner on your subnet. And your product will be as good as the best prediction or the best ensemble you can have over there.
Because that's very, this kind of anchor of a price that then allows you to build whatever you could on top.
The level is pretty high and you had one good archetype of that performance with what you did on prediction market.
That I think is just brilliant.
Do you want to talk about it?
Real player coming in.
Yeah.
You mentioned that point in particular.
You mentioned discrepancy, like you figure out something that is interesting.
I think the anecdote.
I think the outcome of that.
The proof that you have is you've been correctly predicting the direction of one of the assets you're tracking.
Yeah.
A certain amount of time, like to take that icon from that point to where you end up.
Okay, prediction market aren't perfect and you know there's plenty of way to game that.
But cool article guys, by the way, go and check it out. I think you published it on your Twitter.
Yeah.
So taking it from there.
Where do you see, where do you see, you mentioned like option pricing, you mentioned, you know, retail traders, where do you see taking synth data.
What else?
Where do you see most traction?
New York Stock Exchange announced last week.
We've been having 25.
I.
Mean, we've been crypto since like maybe 10 years.
I'm used to see market going on weekend anyway.
So maybe last word on that.
So we're going to mine in this coordinator probabilistic return of a few cryptocurrency.
Precious metals.
A few equity as.
Well that.
You bring again.
Right now.
Where do you see the, are you going to add more like time series or more like assets?
At which speed?
How do you move forward with that?
The cruncher that are listening and what kind of tips you can give I give them like what do you think the most performing miners are actually doing and.
Fitting a famous president.
Right?
And so right now within the game.
We're going to be providing data from Pyth.
Right?
What.
Kind.
Of data are you providing natively?
Yeah.
That's a new feature on Crunch.
By the way, since it's going to be the first time, guys, where when you submit your model into the TE.
You'll be able to also access external data.
So you can have, you know, kind of API calls within the trusted execution environment and, you know, fetch data from, I don't know, maybe you have a proprietary data set somewhere.
Where maybe you have some scraping that you have been doing here and then or maybe you know you have a validator in this particular protocol whether you know when you're gonna I don't know if you already had a soul is not yet into the you.
Have you have Ethereum Bitcoin and and.
So okay perfect maybe you're running some application that runs that maybe you deep into some other networks and you have some information I'm sure some people.
I would love to be able to do that and that's a first on crunch so.
It's good we needed to anyway because there is.
Only a limited information of only limited amount of alpha in price data right and and like we said it's been massively mine anyway so maybe you can go deeper with models but i think it's better to go orthogonal and find new ideas on your data sets on your feature set for sure all right james this is super exciting we are extremely happy i think it's it could not we could not dream about a better coordinator here.
It's really aligned with what we like, what we believe in.
There is massive rewards, guys.
We talk about like 100K a month.
So it's unseen.
Unseen.
But also very competitive.
But we like that anyway.
Guys, I really encourage you if you are a trader, a trading desk.
If you need some pricing data.
I think Synth is going to provide some very, very interesting vectors and great insight in your trading infrastructure or in your strat. So.
So really check this out on their website if you are a cruncher in the coming days maybe it's already released by the moment we release this video you should see on crunchdao.com slash competition slash Synth as a Synth competition we're gonna open a Discord channel where we will be able to exchange and ask questions and etc feel free to go and join James' community as well on their own Discord if you want to go deeper but I think after the first months of warm-up.
Would be great to have you again and maybe check out where we actually are on the leaderboard and start phase two with the mining operation.
All right, let's go.
Good day everyone.
Bye-bye.